it seems that you had a vendetta towards
taylor and disliked her
why is that do you think constantly
targeting her hurt your game
wow no i absolutely didn't have a
vendetta against taylor who was just
working on two opposite sides of the
house i have nothing but love for taylor
but
us working separately just made it look
that way
next question
when you found out about kyle's cookout
comments you told kyle he should have
gone home instead of joseph yet you
tried to save kyle later on in the week
why was that
i just want to change the narrative of
what happens in those type of situations
and
nothing happens until we change exactly
what we're doing with that with
situations like that
next question you questioned why michael
and brittany didn't express their
concerns about kyle sooner if they had
would you have approached your game
differently
absolutely would have approached my game
differently
and then last question
what do you think is the biggest mistake
you made in the game
uh the biggest mistake that i made in
the game was aligning myself with people
who didn't have my best interest in the
game at all